y en directo Ah Vamos hasta Santiago en
Chile con nuestra corresponsal Patricia
Luna porque un día como hoy hace tres
años chile presenció protestas que
iniciaron en el rechazo al aumento de la
tarifa del metro pero que inmediatamente
se convirtieron en un reclamo por mayor
igualdad social un estallido que sacudió
el país y lo encaminó hacia la redacción
de una nueva constitución cuya
aprobación fue rechazada hace poco en un
referendo Patricia Buenas noches
cuéntenos tres años después Cuál es el
ambiente hoy en las calles el
sentimiento entre la sociedad chilena
buenas noches a todos compañeros y a
toda la audiencia en esta jornada
tremendamente
agridulce en chile en el que se
conmemora este tercer aniversario del 18
de octubre aquella fecha que cambió la
historia de chile para siempre pero no
tanto como muchos lo hubiera gustado son
muchas las demandas de la ciudadanía que
salió de forma masiva en la calle que no
se han visto satisfechas en una jornada
que ha estado marcada también por las
manifestaciones y por las acciones
violentas empezaba la jornada con muchos
comercios cerrados en el centro de
Santiago en el lugar donde se han
producido muchas de las manifestaciones
y con una sensación de pánico también de
miedo a lo que pudiera ocurrir en las
calles el gobierno había preparado con
antelación esta jornada y había
desplegado 25.000 carabineros a lo largo
de todo el país esto es casi la mitad de
los efectivos que existen para controlar
los posibles desmanes son así hemos
visto incidentes de violencia habituales
en estas jornadas como son saqueos
incendios de buses ataques abusos con
personas en el interior una jornada que
ha sido violenta no solo en Santiago
también en el norte en ciudades como la
serena y coquimbo en el norte del país
en lugares como el paraíso siempre
sensibles a las protestas y también en
Concepción en la zona de la araucanía en
el sur en según el balance de las
autoridades más de 2.300 personas
salieron en la calle en una jornada que
no fue para nada masiva pero sí que
estuvo marcada por incidentes violentos
700 estas personas acudieron a cometer
actos delictuales Según a manifestó el
subsecretario de interior Manuel
monsalve que manifestó que hubo 18 focos
en 11 puntos del país y que fueron 50
los detenidos según el balance realizado
a las 9 de la noche chilenas este
balance puede ser ampliado porque era un
balance preliminar a lo largo de la
noche puesto que los actos de violencia
continúan mientras hablamos en este
momento patri Cuál ha sido el balance y
los logros tras las demandas sociales
bueno el propio presidente salía a
principio de la mañana a realizar un
discurso en el que manifestaba que el 18
de octubre no fue ni una revuelta
anticabía lista ni una oda a la
violencia como se ha tratado de mostrar
en los últimos meses y realizó un
balance en el que afirmó que se violaron
los Derechos Humanos durante esta fecha
que se cometieron atropellos a los
derechos humanos de muchas personas
recordó muchas de las personas que
resultaron
damnificadas en estos hechos aquellas
personas que fueron fallecidas que
recibieron agresiones sexuales o los más
de 400 personas en Chile que Perdieron
su visión o sus globos oculares como
consecuencia de los ataques a los
Derechos Humanos por parte de las
fuerzas del Estado pero también
manifestó que esto no ha sido en vano y
que se va a seguir trabajando en un
nuevo proceso constitucional que se está
discutiendo en el congreso con avances
todavía tibios pero también en otros
procesos que continúan abiertos en el
gobierno como puede ser el la reforma
tributaria y también la reforma de las
pensiones algunos de los temas en los
que trabaja con de forma ardua el
gobierno de borich en un momento que
también tiene que lograr grandes
mayorías en un congreso que se encuentra
tremendamente fragmentado el propio
presidente hizo una reflexión sobre la
dificultad y la necesidad de alcanzar
estas mayorías para que estas demandas
sociales expresadas por la ciudadanía en
la calle hace tres años que pidieron
sobre todo mayor acceso a la educación a
una mejor salud a unas mejores pensiones
para todos y una nueva constitución se
vean finalmente reflejadas como es el
ansia de todos los chilenos en un día
como hoy un ansia que también se ha
visto modificada por las circunstancias
internacionales Por la alta inflación
que en este momento flagela a la
ciudadanía en chile y por una de la
delincuencia una de las preocupaciones
en este momento de la ciudadanía en el
país